jlo playfully getting out her aggression
with a-rod yesterday in miami
just hours after southern charm star
madison lacroix
broke her silence on this viral tv
moment you flew to miami
an xmlb player madison now reveals she
and her co-stars were actually talking
about a-rod during last week's reunion
show
but quote he's never physically cheated
on his fiancee with me
he contacted me and yes we dm'd but
other than that there was
there was nothing i've never physically
seen him you guys faced
all the time madison stopped well today
a source tells e.t
alex rodriguez never met madison and
doesn't know her this rekindle couple
chloe and tristan are trying for baby
number two i just feel like it's now
time to have another kid
in keeping up's final season the 36 year
old mom to
daughter true reveals she's frozen her
eggs to expand her family
a source tells et the on off couple of
four and a half years
who endured two cheating scandals is
giving their relationship another chance
chloe forgives tristan but she will
never forget
she sees herself marrying tristan one
day but he
has a lot to prove and finally bowed up
jojo siwa reveals she's
booed up i do have the most
amazing wonderful perfect most beautiful
girlfriend
in the whole world you and your
boyfriend broke up
the 17 year old viral sensation who
wasn't ready to share her news with us
back in december says it was her unnamed
new lady
who convinced her to come out now i get
to share
what makes me the happiest with the
world and it makes my heart so happy
and you know what jojo's work life is
going well too she will start a new
nickelodeon musical called the j
team opposite our friend teacher cam oh
who can sing
[Music]
thanks